vítej zpět v Quantum Computing v praxi, jsem Olivia Lan a dnešní třetí díl se zaměří na
experiment qaoa v měřítku utility scale. Pokud jsi s námi od začátku, viděl/a jsi, jak jsme prošli
IBM Quantum Hardware, frameworkem Qiskit patterns a nejnovějšími technikami potlačování chyb, které
výzkumníci a vývojáři používají k rozšiřování Quantum circuits. Cítili jsme, že je opravdu důležité poskytnout ti veškerý tento
kontext a ukázat ti směr, kterým jsme se vydali, ale teď už není důvod čekat, abys viděl/a všechny tyto informace v
praxi. Než začneme, je dobré mít na paměti pár věcí. Vše bude sledovat framework Qiskit
patterns, takže těmito kroky projdeme postupně: zaprvé mapování problému, zadruhé optimalizace circuit, zatřetí
spuštění s Primitives a začtvrté post-processing neboli analýza výsledků. Začneme s poměrně malým příkladem,
abys co nejlépe pochopil/a tyto kroky a jejich účel. Poté probereme velmi podobný, ale mnohem
větší příklad, abychom ti ukázali, jak by se dal problém rozšířit na úroveň 100 qubitů. Dám ti všechny
nástroje, které ti umožní po této přednášce pokračovat a samostatně tento problém spustit. Na závěr, tohle nebude
procházení kódem – ať se snažíme sebevíc, jak děláme pokroky, kód stárne a zastarává. Pokud tedy budeš
sledovat toto video rok po jeho vydání, nechci, aby tě zdržovala syntaxe, která se může časem mírně změnit. Místo toho to bude
podrobná diskuse o logice a zadání problému. K tomuto videu je však přiložen tutoriál s notebookem,
který je připojen v popisu níže. Sledovat kód nebo se k němu vracet po zhlédnutí
této lekce a spustit ho sám/sama ti poskytne co nejlepší vzdělávací zážitek. Takže jako rychlá připomínka –
ne všechny výpočetní problémy jsou vhodné pro Quantum Computing. Jednoduché problémy a základní výpočty nepotřebují
tuto technologii, protože klasické počítače je umí řešit bez problémů. K roku 2024 jsou
tři oblasti, o kterých jsme nejvíce optimističtí: simulace přírody, zpracování dat se složitou
strukturou a v neposlední řadě optimalizace. Optimalizační problémy patří mezi nejtěžší výpočetní
problémy, které lze řešit efektivně. V optimalizačním problému hledáš co největší nebo nejmenší možnou hodnotu
pro danou cost function. U mnoha problémů zájmu je však hledání tohoto extrému exponenciálně
náročnější s velikostí problému. Proto je tak těžké to vypočítat. Jako příklad si představ,
jak obtížné může být vypočítat optimální letecké trasy nebo doručovací trasy po celé zemi. V této lekci se budeme
zabývat konkrétním optimalizačním problémem zvaným Max cut, který budeme řešit pomocí Quantum
algoritmu zvaného quantum approximation optimization algorithm neboli qaoa. Co je tedy problém Max cut? Problém
maximálního řezu je typ kombinatorického optimalizačního problému definovaného na grafu, jehož cílem je
rozdělit vrcholy grafu do dvou podmnožin tak, aby počet hran mezi těmito dvěma podmnožinami byl
maximální. Například v tomto grafu je každý uzel propojen takto a maximální řez je znázorněn touto klikatou
čárou, která rozděluje uzly do fialové skupiny a šedé skupiny. Způsob, jak to provést přeříznutím co největšího
počtu hran, je přeřezat pět hran. V tomto grafu je, protože je tak malý,
snadné vyzkoušet několik možných řezů na papíře nebo dokonce v hlavě a zjistit, že pět je nejlepší možná
volba. Ale představ si, že se počet uzlů zdvojnásobí a pak ztrojnásobí – to se rychle stane nemožným provést
ručně a po určitém počtu je to tak obtížné, že i superpočítače mají problém spolehlivě vrátit nejlepší odpověď. Je to proto, že
maximální počet řezů roste exponenciálně s počtem uzlů. I když to může znít trochu abstraktně,
existuje mnoho reálných problémů, které lze formulovat jako problém Max cut, jako například detekce podvodů ve financích,
shlukování grafů, návrh sítí a návrh VLSI, ale také analýza sociálních médií.
Ten se sociálními médii je obzvláště snadno pochopitelný. Řekněme, že chceš najít skupinu jedinců s co nejvíce
možnými spojeními s dalšími jedinci na platformě sociálních médií, abys identifikoval/a mocné uživatele nebo lidi, kteří mají
největší vliv ve skupině. Firmy se o to skutečně pokoušejí poměrně často. Poslední poznámka: Max cut je často
podrutinou většího problému, takže nemusí definovat samotnou aplikaci, ale používá se v zákulisí. Je to
mnohem běžnější, než si naivně myslíš. Teď je čas začít.
Prvním krokem je vytvoření grafu. Můžeš to udělat importem pythonového balíčku nazvaného rustworks. Definuj,
s kolika uzly pracuješ, zadáním čísla n, pak přidej uzly do grafu G. Také budeš muset
nakreslit hrany. Uděláme to ručně tak, že je jednoduše vypíšeme v poli, kde ukážeš poslední
číslo, které určuje váhu hrany neboli jak silně jsou spojeny dva zadané uzly. Zde se budeme
držet váhy jedna pro všechny, ale možná si rád/a pohraješ s váhou později a uvidíš, jak se mění řešení.
Abys získal/a představu o tom, co váha znamená v tomto kontextu, vraťme se k příkladu se sociálními médii. Můžeš o tom přemýšlet
tak, že váha vyjadřuje, jak velký vliv má jedna osoba na druhou. Tvé spojení s manželem/manželkou nebo příbuzným
by pravděpodobně dostalo vyšší váhu než někdo, kdo je jen tvým známým. Teď nakresli svůj graf.
Tutoriál připojený níže ti ukáže správnou syntaxi. Než se zamyslíme nad tím, jak
namapovat tento problém na Quantum circuit, postavme si kontext o tom, jak se problém Max cut stane optimalizačním
problémem. Začneme tím, že nejprve uvažujeme o minimalizaci funkce f(x), kde vstup X je
n-dimenzionální vektor, jehož složky odpovídají každému uzlu grafu. Tuto funkci budeme od nynějška označovat
jako naši cost function. Poté musíme každou z těchto složek omezit tak, aby byla buď nula nebo
jedna – to znamená na jedné nebo druhé straně řezu. Funkci lze zapsat jako
pár uzlů xi a xj, který nám říká, zda příslušná hrana je v řezu. Výraz xi + xj
minus xi*xj tedy říká, zda je hrana v řezu. Pokud se tento výraz rovná
jedné, znamená to, že hrana je v řezu, jinak je nula a hrana v řezu není. Problém hledání
maximálního počtu hran v řezu lze pak formulovat jako maximalizaci této funkce. Dále skutečně
přidáme globální znaménko mínus k této funkci, čímž je nový problém ekvivalentní hledání minima této funkce.
WEBVTT
místo toho, a tedy minimum f(x) v tomto případě bude tehdy, když je počet hran procházejících řezem
maximální. Tento problém formulujeme jako minimalizační, protože nám to umožní ho později namapovat na problém
minimalizace energie neboli hledání základního stavu, ve kterém jsou kvantové počítače přirozeně velmi dobré.
Ale pamatuj, že zde zatím nic nesouvisí s Quantum Computing. Stále potřebujeme přeformulovat tento problém do
něčeho, čemu kvantový počítač rozumí. Teď jsme připraveni pustit se do práce a
prvním krokem je namapovat problém na Quantum circuit. Nemusí být zřejmé, jak
přejdeme z grafu, jaký jsme právě nakreslili, na Quantum circuit, ale pojďme to vzít pomalu. Pamatuj, že se
pokusíme vyřešit tento problém Max cut pomocí qaoa. V algoritmu qaoa chceme nakonec mít operátor –
hamiltonian – který bude použit k reprezentaci cost function našeho problému, a také parametrizovaný
circuit, ansatz neboli zkušební stav, který použijeme k reprezentaci kvantových stavů, jež jsou vzdělané odhady nebo kandidáti
pro řešení problému. Můžeme vzorkovat z těchto kandidátních stavů a pak je vyhodnotit
pomocí cost function – v tomto případě f(x) – ale musíme ji vyjádřit způsobem, který
je přirozený pro kvantový počítač. K tomu využijeme řadu matematických
transformací pro vyjádření f(x) jako energetické funkce – hamiltonianu. Prvním krokem tohoto
procesu je vyjádřit problém minimalizace f(x) jako kvadratický neomezený binární optimalizační
problém neboli QUBO. QUBO je obecný způsob formulace těchto kombinatorických optimalizačních problémů.
Zde je Q matice N×N reálných čísel, N odpovídá počtu
uzlů v našem grafu – pěti pro tento příklad – a X je stejný vektor binárních proměnných z původní
formulace. Pro efektivní spuštění algoritmu qaoa musíme vyjádřit náš optimalizační problém pomocí
hamiltonianu, což je matematický operátor reprezentující celkovou energii systému. Konkrétně chceme
vytvořit hamiltonian cost function s vlastností, že energie jeho základního stavu neboli minimální eigenvalue
odpovídá minimu funkce, která kóduje maximální počet řezů na grafu G. Jakmile máme
tento hamiltonian, vše, co potřebujeme udělat k vyřešení optimalizačního problému, je připravit základní stav hamiltonianu na kvantovém počítači a poté
vzorkování z tohoto stavu s vysokou pravděpodobností vrátí řešení minimalizace f(x). Ukazuje se,
že máme štěstí, protože problém QUBO je velmi úzce spjat s a vlastně výpočetně ekvivalentní
jednomu z nejslavnějších a nejrozšířenějších hamiltonianů ve fyzice – Isingovskému hamiltonianu. Abychom přepsali problém QUBO
jako tento Isingovský hamiltonian, stačí provést jednoduchou změnu proměnné pro přechod od
Booleovských proměnných 0 a 1 ke spinovým proměnným minus jedna a jedna. Tento krok je
přímočarý a je podrobněji ukázán v příloze přiloženého notebooku pro zájemce. Na konci je minimalizace tohoto výrazu QUBO
stejná jako minimalizace tohoto výrazu. Přepsáním mírně znovu
dostaneme hamiltonian cost function, kde minimum výrazu reprezentuje základní stav a Z
se stává operátorem Pauli, zatímco b je reálný skalární koeficient. Teď, když máme náš
hamiltonian, je snadné ho přepsat pomocí dvou lokálních ZZ Pauliho operátorů, které se snadno převedou na
dva kubické gates v našem Quantum circuit. Viz přidružený notebook pro informace o tom, jak se to provede, ale výstupem
je tento řádek zde. Poznamenejme, že v našem příkladu je
šest objektů neboli Pauliho řetězců, protože každý reprezentuje hranu v grafu. Délka řetězce odpovídá počtu
uzlů, takže IIIZZ je pět uzlů a řetězec se bude skládat z
identit na všech pozicích kromě indexů uzlů zapojených do hrany, které budou mít Z členy. V Qiskit
jsou bitové řetězce reprezentující qubity indexovány pozpátku. Například hrana mezi uzly 0 a 1 bude zakódována jako
IIIZZ. Jakmile je hamiltonian zapsán pomocí Pauliho operátorů, jsme připraveni sestavit náš
Quantum circuit. Tento Quantum circuit nám pomůže vzorkovat dobré řešení z kvantového počítače. Algoritmus qaoa
je inspirován adiabatickým teorémem, který říká, že pokud začneme v základním stavu časově závislého
hamiltonianu a pokud se hamiltonian vyvíjí dostatečně pomalu a dostane dostatek času, konečný stav bude základním
stavem konečného hamiltonianu. qaoa lze chápat jako diskrétní Trotterovu verzi kvantového
adiabatického algoritmu, kde každý Trotterův krok představuje vrstvu, kterou nazveme P. Takže
místo vyvíjení z jednoho stavu do druhého budeme v každé vrstvě P přepínat tam a zpět mezi naší cost function
hamiltonianem a něčím, co se nazývá mixovací hamiltonian – o tom se dozvíme více za chvilku. Ale bod, který chci zdůraznit,
je, že qaoa má výhodu v tom, že je rychlejší než kvantový adiabatický algoritmus, ale vrací přibližné
výsledky místo optimálních. V limitu, kde počet vrstev jde do nekonečna, qaoa konverguje k adiabatickému
případu, ale to je samozřejmě výpočetně velmi nákladné. Pro vytvoření našeho Quantum circuit
budeme aplikovat střídající se operátory parametrizované gamma a beta, které
budou reprezentovat diskretizaci časového vývoje. Takže tři hlavní části
qaoa circuit jsou: zaprvé počáteční zkušební stav šedou barvou, což je základní
stav mixéru z adiabatického stavu vývoje vytvořeného aplikací Hadamard gate na každý qubit. Zadruhé
vývoj cost function, který již máme tmavě fialově, a zatřetí vývoj pod mixovacím
hamiltonianem, o kterém jsme zatím nehovořili – světle fialově. Náš počáteční hamiltonian je
nazýván mixérem, protože jeho základní stav je superpozicí všech možných bitových řetězců zájmu, čímž
vynucuje směs všech možných řešení na začátku. Mixovací hamiltonian je jednoduchý součet Pauliho X
operací na každém uzlu grafu. Qiskit ti umožňuje použít jiný vlastní mixovací operátor, pokud chceš, ale
v tomto případě budeme používat standardní. Takže jak vidíš, s Qiskit je hodně práce za nás
odvedeno, takže přijít s mixovacím hamiltonianem a počátečním stavem je triviální. Jedinou prací, kterou jsme museli udělat, bylo
WEBVTT
najít cost function. Každá iterace těchto operátorů se nazývá vrstva. Tyto vrstvy lze chápat jako
diskretizace časového vývoje systému, jak bylo dříve popsáno. Střídající se vzor pochází z
Trotterovy dekompozice a aproximuje exponenciální funkce nekomutujících matic. Obecně platí, že čím více vrstev nebo
kroků zahrneme, tím blíže budeme ke spojitému časovému vývoji, takže teoreticky čím přesnější výsledek budeme
mít. Pro tento příklad ale začneme vzorkováním se dvěma vrstvami. Pamatuj, že jak hamiltonian cost function, tak
mixér jsou parametrizovány. Stále potřebujeme přijít s optimálními hodnotami pro gamma a
beta. Uznávám, že to bylo hodně informací, a pokud vidíš tento typ matematiky poprvé, může být složitý. Naštěstí jednou z úžasných
věcí na Qiskit je, že hodně z toho, co jsme právě prošli, lze provést automaticky bez velké námahy uživatele. Je dobré rozumět tomu, co se
děje v zákulisí, zejména při rozšiřování na větší experimenty, ale nebudeš muset dělat veškerou tuto práci
ručně pokaždé. Nyní jsme namapovali náš problém na Quantum circuit. Byl to kousek práce,
ale neboj se, čím víc to děláš, tím snáze a intuitivněji to jde. Teď jsme připraveni přejít ke kroku dvě:
optimalizaci našeho circuit pro Hardware. I když circuit, který jsme právě vytvořili, vypadá poměrně jednoduše a
pomáhá budovat intuitivní porozumění, pamatuj, že kvantový čip nerozumí tomu, co tento abstraktní
blok je. Potřebujeme ho převést na sérii jednoho a dvou qubitových gates, které jsou nativní pro hardware. A když říkám
nativní, mám na mysli, že to bude přefaktorováno do toho, co lze přímo provést na qubitech. Takovéto circuits se
říká, že jsou zapsány v architektuře instrukční sady backend, což možná uvidíš zkráceno jako ISA circuits.
Modul transpiler Qiskit SDK nabízí řadu transpilačních průchodů, které mohou
provádět širokou škálu transformací circuit. Chceme se ujistit, že náš circuit je optimalizován pro náš
účel. Připomeň si z naší předchozí lekce, že transpilační proces zahrnuje několik kroků: mapování
qubitů v circuit neboli rozhodovacích proměnných na fyzické qubity na zařízení, rozbalení instrukcí v
Quantum circuit do nativních hardwarových instrukcí, kterým backend skutečně rozumí, směrování qubitů
v circuit, které přímo interagují, na fyzické qubity, jež jsou vzájemně sousední,
a jako vždy, více podrobností o tom najdeš v dokumentaci
na webu. Teď přichází vzrušující krok, kde si vybereme, na kterém backend spustit náš circuit. Toto musíme udělat
před krokem transpilace, protože transpiler optimalizuje odlišně pro různé procesory. To je ještě jeden důvod, proč je
důležité, že Qiskit dokáže tolik z této fáze automatizovat. Nechtěl/a bys muset optimalizovat svůj circuit ručně –
to lze udělat, ale někdy je to složité a velmi časově náročné – jen aby sis uvědomil/a, že vlastně chceš spustit
svůj circuit na jiném procesoru s jinými vlastnostmi, a pak musíš veškerou tuto práci dělat znovu. Předej
svůj backend výběru přes funkci transpiler a nezapomeň specifikovat úroveň optimalizace. Tentokrát
jsem vybral/a optimalizační úroveň tři, která je nejvyšší a nejkomplexnější úroveň optimalizace.
A to je vlastně vše pro krok dva. Můj circuit byl transpilován automaticky a nakreslil/a jsem ho zde, abys
viděl/a, jak byl přeložen do jednoho a dvou qubitových gates. Teď nastává čas pro krok tři:
spuštění circuit s Qiskit Primitives. Doposud jsme transpilovali circuit a ponechali parametry gamma a
beta tak jak jsou, ale nemůžeme skutečně spustit circuit bez specifikace hodnot těchto parametrů. V workflow qaoa
jsou optimální parametry qaoa nalezeny v iterační optimalizační smyčce, kde spouštíme sérii
vyhodnocení circuit a používáme klasický optimizer k nalezení optimálních parametrů beta a gamma. Potřebujeme však někde začít,
takže jsem implementoval/a počáteční odhady pro gamma1, gamma2 a beta1, beta2 jako π/2 a π
resp. Také si všimni, že budeme používat optimizer k hledání lepších řešení pro gamma a beta.
Protože počítám pouze dvě vrstvy, to je vše, co potřebuji, ale pokud vytvoříš přesnější qaoa circuit,
zahrneš více vrstev a tedy budeš potřebovat optimalizované gamma a beta pro každou sekvenční
vrstvu. Teď si chvilku udělejme pauzu a připomeňme si naše možnosti pro Primitives. Máme estimator a
sampler. Který z nich si myslíš, že budeme používat pro tento typ úlohy? Ať jsi uhádl/a jakýkoli,
vlastně máš pravdu – budeme používat jak estimator, tak sampler. Pro počáteční optimalizační
smyčku budeme potřebovat estimator, ale sampler použijeme později pro přečtení konečného
řešení. Jsme téměř připraveni spustit náš algoritmus, slibuji, ale velmi rychle je důležité poznamenat, že svůj
job můžeš odeslat různými způsoby, které se nazývají execution modes. Nejprve máme job mode – jednoduchý
primitives požadavek estimatoru nebo sampleru bez context manageru. Circuits a vstupy jsou zabaleny jako primitive
unified blocks (PUBs) a odeslány jako execution task na kvantovém
počítači. Batch mode je multi-job manager pro efektivní spouštění experimentů složených z řady
nezávislých úloh. Batch mode použij pro současné odesílání více primitive jobs. Session mode je vyhrazené
okno pro spouštění multi-job workloadu. To umožňuje prémiových uživatelům experimentovat s variačními algoritmy
předvídatelnějším způsobem a dokonce spouštět více experimentů současně s využitím paralelismu
stacku. Sessions použij pro iterativní workflow a experimenty vyžadující vyhrazený přístup. Pro experiment qaoa je
session dobrá volba, pokud k ní máš přístup, protože budeš muset vyzkoušet více circuits pro různé hodnoty beta
a gamma. Dobře, teď se vraťme k našemu optimalizačnímu problému. Již jsme
definovali hamiltonian cost function HC a celý workflow je tento: algoritmus qaoa
začíná inicializací qubitů v superpozičním stavu a poté aplikuje ansatz s P vrstvami.
Inicializuje parametry gamma a beta a poté spustí circuit pomocí Primitives estimatoru. Jakmile vypočítáme
střední hodnoty, použijeme scipy optimizer zvaný COBYLA. COBYLA
optimalizuje cost function klasicky mimo QPU. Jakmile jsou tyto hodnoty gamma a beta aktualizovány,
opakujeme. Budeme to dělat, dokud hodnota celkové cost function nekonverguje a nedosáhne nejnižší hodnoty.
WEBVTT
Poté vybereme hodnoty gamma a beta, které odpovídají této nízké hodnotě nákladů, a spustíme circuit naposledy,
tentokrát pomocí sampleru. Toto je výsledek spuštění COBYLA optimizeru s mými počátečními odhady. Zde vidíš,
že hodnota cost function v průběhu iterací začíná trochu kolísat – jde nahoru a dolů, ale
pak se ustálí na nízké hodnotě. Použijeme tyto poslední hodnoty gamma a beta odpovídající minimální hodnotě
vyhodnocení cost function pro spuštění circuit naposledy a vzorkování bitového řetězce, který nám dá maximální
řez. Nyní s optimalizovanými hodnotami pro gamma a beta spustíme circuit naposledy k nalezení nejlepšího
možného bitového řetězce pomocí sampleru. Konkrétní hodnoty, které používám, jsou uvedeny zde, ale pamatuj, že když se
pokusíš o to sám/sama nebo jen znovu spustíš stejný tutoriál v notebooku, tyto hodnoty se mohou mírně změnit. Teď spustíme
náš optimalizovaný circuit s těmito hodnotami a najdeme kandidátní řešení pro náš problém Max cut. Pokud jsi používal/a
sessions, to již není nutné, protože spouštíme jen jednu poslední úlohu. Teď se konečně podíváme na
fázi post-processingu a nalezení konečného řešení. Nejprve vykreslíme všechny
možné kombinace uzlů, které jsme převedli na bitové řetězce, jako histogram. Hned uvidíš, že
když jsem to spustil/a, našel/a jsem čtyři řešení a ta zvýraznil/a fialově, která jsou pravděpodobnější než jakékoli jiné řešení.
Nejpravděpodobnější a tedy nejpravděpodobnější řešení jako bitový řetězec je 01 01. Všimni si prosím pořadí qubitů,
které je v grafu obrácené. Při pohledu na nejpravděpodobnější řešení si všimneme, že uzly 0 a tři jsou seskupeny dohromady
a podobně uzly 1, 2 a čtyři. Nyní konečně můžeme vykreslit nejpravděpodobnější
bitový řetězec zpět jako graf a pamatuj, že bitový řetězec jednoduše odpovídá číslům uzlů a zda jsou zahrnuty
– označeny jedničkou – nebo nezahrnuty – označeny nulou – v naší skupině. Když nyní nakreslíme řez, vidíme na vlastní oči
přibližnou linii pro nejlepší řez, která představuje ideální seskupení všech pěti uzlů, jak jsem zde nakreslil/a.
Je tu však jedna věc, o níž chci strávit chvíli hovořem, a to skutečnost, že správné řešení není jedinečné.
Kvůli symetrii tohoto grafu existuje více správných řešení. Místo toho, aby uzly 0 a tři byly
uvnitř řezu, mohly by tam být uzly 2 a čtyři, a vidíš, že vše, co jsem musel/a udělat, bylo otočit svůj řez tak, aby
zahrnul tyto nové body. Toto řešení pěti zůstává stejné.
Podívejme se znovu na histogram a čtyři nejpravděpodobnější řešení chvilku. Poslední dvě řešení jsou ta,
která jsme právě vykreslili, a jsou stejně správná. Ale to není vše – mohli bychom také obrátit barvy pro všechna
správná řešení a tentokrát jen přemýšlet o uzlech jako o těch uvnitř versus vně řezu. Na
předchozím slidu jsme identifikovali dvě jedinečná správná řešení, ale ve skutečnosti existují ještě dvě další řešení – jedno odpovídající
opaku každého z nich. Vidíš, jak zde, kde jsem nakreslil/a zbývající dvě řešení, jsem pouze obrátil/a
barvy. Jediným problémem je, že algoritmus vlastně toto čtvrté poslední řešení nenašel ani neidentifikoval jako
jedno ze čtyř nejpravděpodobnějších. Bylo páté. Čtvrté řešení, které algoritmus identifikoval,
je vlastně nesprávné, a kdybys ho nakreslil/a, viděl/a bys, že toto řešení má pouze čtyři řezy, a protože ostatní
mají pět a čtyři je zřejmě méně než pět, je to zjevně špatně. Pointa je,
že jde o přibližný algoritmus. Není neomylný a není správný 100 % času. Musíš
použít vlastní znalosti a porozumění k ověření řešení. Stojí za to zdůraznit, že
tato chyba může pocházet z několika míst. Může to být přibližná povaha samotného algoritmu a malý
počet vrstev, které jsem použil/a. Může to být chyba konečného vzorkování, která by se dala snížit, kdybych zvýšil/a
počet shots v mém experimentu. Nebo to může být chyba čtení, protože čtvrté reálné řešení se liší jen o jeden
bit. Důvod, proč poukazuji na všechny tyto možnosti, je ten, že to je to, co je třeba, abyste se plně stali
praktiky kvantového computingu. Musíš rozumět výkonu hardwaru a tomu, jak to může přispívat
k určitým typům chyb a jak je opravovat. Ale nezapomeňme, že
existovalo 32 možných řešení bitového řetězce a čtyři reálná řešení byla zahrnuty v top pěti
nejlepších kandidátech, přičemž jsem použil/a jen dvě vrstvy. Obecně, pokud chci zvýšit šanci nalezení
nejlepšího Max cut pokaždé, zvýšil/a bych hloubku vrstev. Jsou tu některé jemnosti, ale to je na pozdější
díl. Teď ti nechám zkusit to sám/sama, ale tentokrát budeš používat 100
qubitů. Pokud tedy začneme kreslením 100-qubitového grafu, vidíš, že již není přímočaré ani možné
odhadnout pohledem, kde by se maximální řez nacházel. Je jednoduše příliš mnoho možností, abys to mohl/a vybrat ručně. Ale
řešení tohoto problému pomocí qaoa je stále zcela proveditelné a můžeš sledovat přesně stejný workflow, který jsme použili pro 5
qubitů. Za chvíli tě pustím na vlastní pěst a pověřím tě provedením tohoto experimentu, ale než to udělám,
shrňme si. Připomeň si, že šest kroků jakékoli qaoa úlohy jsou následující: zaprvé definovat
hamiltonian cost function tak, aby jeho základní stav kódoval řešení optimalizačního problému; zadruhé definovat
mixovací hamiltonian; zatřetí sestavit operátory odpovídající exponenciálním
hamiltonianům; začtvrté sestavit circuit – bude se skládat z počátečního základního stavu mixéru a střídajících se
opakovaných vrstev cost function a vývoje pod mixovacím hamiltonianem; zapáté připravit počáteční stav a
použít klasické výpočetní techniky k optimalizaci parametrů; zašesté spustit circuit, měřit výstupní bitové řetězce
a hledat nejpravděpodobnější řešení. Teď pár poznámek:
Použil/a jsem optimalizační úroveň tři pro svůj 5-qubitový příklad, ale to možná nebylo nutné a správná odpověď by
se vrátila i při nižší úrovni optimalizace, protože hloubka circuit byla poměrně nízká pro 5
qubitů. Ale pro 100 qubitů a velkou hloubku circuit téměř jistě budeš potřebovat nejvyšší úroveň
optimalizace pro nalezení správné odpovědi. Také mej na paměti, že jednou z nejnáročnějších částí typického utility
scale workflow je fáze mapování a nalezení grafu, který dobře koresponduje s IBM's heavy hex topology. Pokud bys
dělal/a tuto práci od nuly, bezpochyby bys tomu věnoval/a hodně času. Pro teď tato část byla
WEBVTT
udělána za tebe, protože to není hlavní smysl tohoto cvičení. Ale mej na paměti, že to je něco, co budeme
vyžadovat trénovat, a spouštění rozsáhlé úlohy není vždy přímočaré. Tomuto se budeme věnovat
podrobněji v epizodě 4. Tvůj konečný circuit bude samozřejmě vypadat mnohem chaotičtěji než circuit spuštěný na 5 qubitech.
Ale na druhou stranu mám pocit, že pohled na tento circuit a na to, kolik gates má, s vědomím, že
máš schopnost to skutečně spustit na reálných Quantum procesorech, je docela
působivé. A toto bylo mé konečné řešení. Vidíš, že algoritmus je jistě schopný seskupit tyto
uzly do dvou skupin a údajně identifikovat nejlepší Max cut, který je rozděluje jako přechod od dvou množin
k samotné linii Max cut. Je triviální – kdekoli se barva mění podél linií spojujících uzly, to označuje,
kde by měla být linie Max cut nakreslena. Když jsem to spustil/a, hodnota Max cut, které jsem byl/a schopen/schopna dosáhnout, je
84. Tak to zkus sám/sama a dej mi vědět v komentářích, zda jsi dosáhl/a podobného výsledku. Zkus tři vrstvy, možná čtyři, zkus
změnit váhy mezi uzly a uvidíš, jak to mění výsledek. Je tu spousta zajímavých experimentů,
které můžeme spustit s qaoa. Pamatuj, že není zaručeno, že jsem právě našel/la nejlepší možné
řešení. Víme, že je to dobré řešení, ale pro zábavu tě vyzývám, abys mě porazil/a. Uvidíš, jestli dokážeš dosáhnout
lepšího výsledku než 84. Závěrem – qaoa je velmi dynamický
algoritmus a je tu mnoho heuristik a stále hodně co objevovat. Poskytuje hodně prostoru pro učení nových
věcí o oblasti optimalizace obecně. V optimalizačním prostoru se toho nedávno hodně děje,
jak dokazují všechny archivní články, které byly nedávno publikovány online o qaoa nebo optimalizaci. A co je
opravdu skvělé, je, že konečně ne všechny tyto články jsou teoretické. Teoretici pracují a studují
qaoa roky, ale nyní se zapojují i experimentalisté, protože konečně máme hardware
jako procesory IBM, které jsou schopné spouštět mnoho z těchto experimentů. Přecházíme z imaginárního prostoru
do reálného světa a to je velmi vzrušující. Ano, stále je toho hodně co udělat a stále existuje
spousta chyb, se kterými se musíme naučit pracovat, ale děláme rychlý pokrok a ty, kdo sleduje toto
video – pokud jsi to dotáhl/a až sem – jsi schopen/schopna spouštět tyto experimenty sám/sama. Jdi prosím zkusit spustit svůj vlastní
100-qubitový experiment a dej nám vědět, jak to dopadlo. Sleduj tutoriál a budeš v dobrých rukou. A pokud
máš jakékoli otázky nebo se zasekneš, neboj se – všichni jsme se tak cítili nebo měli stejné otázky, když jsme začínali
se učit toto. Dej ze sebe maximum, dej nám vědět, na jaké otázky narážíš, a uvidíme se příště.
[Hudba]